Hello. Hello my dispatchers, my
listeners. I'm your author, your
narrator, your host, Scipio Eeroditis.
And today I am honored to be uh joined
by Raymond Ibrahim, prolific author and
public speaker on the Middle East and
Islam. He is the author of 11 books
including Defenders of the West, Sword
and Scimitar, and then his uh latest
book coming out on November 25th, The
Two Swords of Christ, which I'm sure
we're going to be talking about today.
But uh Mr. Ibrahim, if you could just
introduce yourself to the audience for
those who are unfamiliar with yourself
and your work.
>> Yeah, sure. Uh Raymond Ibrahim, um I've
uh I don't know where to start, but um
I've been involved in this field for
quite some time. My family from from
from a personal point of view is um
Coptic Christians from Egypt. So I was
born here but of course uh I grew up
sort of um very familiar with what
happens in the Middle East, the Islamic
world, uh Muslim Christian relations. I
had a I had a natural interest obviously
growing up in it uh hearing that and uh
also grew up bilingual speaking Arabic
and English. traveled to the Middle East
frequently, especially in my youth and
in my latter years. And um uh but also
sort of professionally and academically
ended up in this field. Um academically
I uh my focus has been history minoring
in philosophy and English and um I very
early on gravitated towards this nexus
of Christian Muslim interaction
especially in the medieval era and the
early Islam 7th 8th nth centuries. Um my
thesis was about one of the first
military conflict the battle of Yarmmuk.
uh and the chair, my mentor essentially,
professor and still friend was Victor
Davis Hansen. People get a kick out of
that because he's uh become so popular.
And um anyway after that I went to
Georgetown University and continued my
post-graduate studies but I never
finished PhD um for uh because the
exigencies of life got in the way and I
had to move and long story short but I
also worked at the Library of Congress
in the Middle Eastern department and
dealt with a lot of books that deal with
the topics that I discuss. Um so I have
had a long background in it. My first
published piece came out I think in 2005
so we're talking about two decades now.
And um in in these more recent years,
I've been uh kind of I used to write a
lot about just Islam in general, Islamic
doctrine, Islamic terrorism, the modern
era, and a lot about the persecution of
Christians. Um because again, like I
said, for personal interest reasons.
>> Sure.
>> And I even have a book about it,
Crucified Again. I actually just
recently, it just got re I only recently
um managed to reprint a few copies.
Crucified Again, exposing Islam's new
war against Christians.
Um, but in my more recent years, I've
gone back to my initial interest, which
is history. And I've been writing a lot
of books like Sword and Scimitar,
Defenders of the West, the new book, Two
Swords of Christ, uh, examining once
again where I had left off in my college
years, um, the sort of long war, the
historic war between Christendom and
Islam specifically. Um and yeah, so I've
been a fellow at various think tanks and
um done done a lot of other kind of
other than my writing, my book writing
and now I have a new YouTube channel or
it's rather old but it's new because I
only started recently kind of posting
videos and uh doing other things of
course um that I can't necessarily talk
about but yeah that's it in a nutshell.
>> Yeah. No, thank you. It's uh I mean
that's a good place to start right the
beginning of all this contrary to uh how
often this issue is framed within
popular media and academic circles right
you know the Christian and Islamic
relations did not begin you know in
1095. So if you could uh just walk us
through the early history of you know
some of that conflict.
Well, yeah. I think that's very
important and in fact the way you just
framed it is very important because 1095
is the beginning of the first crusade
and to so many people in the west
especially in America as well. Um when
you talk about the historic conflict
between Islam and the west or
christryendom it always starts at 1095
you know and um in fact and there's a
reason for that because the academics
have have pretended that that's where it
starts. I actually made a video and I've
written a lot of articles about one
quote from a Georgetown professor who I
knew, uh, John Espazito, who back in the
day, you know, in the 2010s and so forth
was very popular and, you know, he he
was the editor of the Oxford uh, series
on Islam and um, you know, all these
intelligence and political agencies
would reach out to him for his
consultation about Islam, etc. And he
said, and I've quoted it so many times
that I think I've memorized it verbatim,
but he has a sentence in his book called
uh I believe the book is called Islam,
the straight path. And he says, "Five
centuries of peaceful coexistence
between Muslims and Christians elapsed
before an imperial papal power play um
led to a series of so-called holy wars
which have left uh centuries of of
misunderstanding and distrust from
Muslims towards the west. So what he's
saying is that those five centuries that
he's referring to is everything before
1095, before the first crusade. And he's
trying to say that before the first
crusade, there was nothing but peaceful
coexistence between Muslims and
Christians. And it all started thanks to
those pesky crusaders and their imperial
papal power play, etc. Well, the reality
and as I really document it in my um my
first real major book, um I actually had
pulled out all these books because I'm
doing something with them, so I I have
them here. But anyway, this book, Sword
and Scimitar, 14 centuries of war
between Islam and the West. That book
was to was based on tracing the history
of conflict between Islam and the West.
And the first crusade is halfway through
the book. Actually, a little past it.
It's chapter five. There's eight
chapters. Okay. So, the first crusade is
chapter five. What does that tell you?
The first four chapters actually deal
with how Islam conquered and terrorized
threequarters of Christendom before the
first crusade. Okay. So for example it's
it's like it's almost axiomatic amongst
westerners that you know North Africa
and the Middle East Mina you know any
everything from Turkey and um you know I
always in my head I'm confusing past and
present names but uh to give them their
present names all the Middle East
basically. Okay, so Syria, most of Iraq,
modern day Lebanon, Israel, Jordan, PA
territories, Egypt, all the way west,
okay? You know, Libya, Algeria, Tunisia,
Morocco, people think that's always been
Islamic. In fact, that's really been
more Christian than Europe historically.
So on the eve of Islam, when Muhammad
came to power in the 7th century, that
area was the heart of Christendom. It
wasn't Europe really. All you had in
Europe, the main center of course was
Rome. But in the east, you had
Constantinople, you had Alexandria, you
had Antioch, you had Jerusalem. All of
those are the five centers of
Christianity. And those four other than
Rome got conquered in the name of Islam
permanently. And Rome was even raided in
the nth century by Muslims. In fact, the
walls that are around the Vatican were
built precisely to fend off against
Sarris pirates uh who came frequently in
the 9th century and even later. So
anyway, uh the long and short of it is
Islam waged a total war on the Christian
world on everyone actually they went
further east of course conquering uh
Persia and Ind portions of India and
further on and later on of course they
went in subsaharan Africa but for our
purposes um if you want to talk about
the west they conquered uh like I said
all those Christian regions by the sword
through violence uh and that's what I
get into in the book I I actually what I
do is I always go to the primary sources
I'm done looking at I look at secondary
sources just to find proof of their
malfeasence these academics and how they
lie and misrepresent but if you go to
the primary sources it was a total
allout jihad and it's articulated just
the way I so when ISIS gets up and
boasts about how our ancestors the
Islamic ancestors conquered and they
beheaded and they gave Christians three
choices or everyone Christians Jews and
everyone uh or the people of the book
three choices Yeah, that's actually
true. That's what Islamic history
teaches. That's what Western history in
its own way also teaches. Um, obviously
in early Western Christian writings,
they didn't even know what was going on.
They just know these are Sarris who who
had a hatred for the cross, okay?
Because they very much would break it
and and desecrate churches. So that's
how they saw it in 7th century. I'm
thinking of people like Sophinus, the
patriarch of Jerusalem, for example, who
was an eyewitness. Um, but anyway, so
this goes on and on and on and I don't
know where you want to end off or you
have more specific questions, but I mean
we can spend the entire I can just keep
rattling and talking about this long
history because I got 14 centuries to
callull from. Uh, but you know it goes
on to let's just put it this way by in
one century after Muhammad dies his
traditional death date is 632. In 732,
Islam has conquered essentially uh one
or twothirds of what was then the
Christian world, North Africa, the
Middle East has had already conquered
Spain and now is in the middle of France
because 732 is the battle of Tours
Poier. Um and even after that battle,
people think it was a great victory. was
but after that battle they were still
all around southern France and complete
and in the Mediterranean and went on to
conquer virtually every middle uh
Mediterranean island which is of course
what led to the um attack that I
mentioned on Rome itself I believe it's
around um 850 or so the year but and
then after that you know so that's
before the crusades the crusades was
essentially uh you know that had
happened Christians in Europe were now
sort of the embattled Europe became the
final bastion of Christendom. Okay, the
final hold out except for Spain which
was conquered and um they continued
experiencing more aggression and
violence. Um and then right before the
first crusade you had an espic a new
sort of wave of persecution because this
is when the Turks come to power
especially the Seljic Turks and um
they're now Muslims and they're they're
following the whole logic jihad logic
you know the enemies the infidel we give
them the three choices it's if they
don't convert we kill them etc. And um
so right before the first crusade you
know beginning really in the 1030s I'd
say they started coming in and
conquering Asia Minor which is today
Turkey and uh you know horrific
slaughter especially of Armenians
Georgian and Greeks the further west you
go into Asia Minor and if you look if
you consult someone like Matthew Adessa
who's a near contemporary I think he's
writing in the 12th century you know
just a few decades after the first
crusades a couple decades I think after
the first crusade and the numbers that
he gives of well it was just mass
carnage. When people talk about the
Armenian genocide uh you know in the
early 20th century late 19th century
they forget that this has been going on
for actually a millennium before that.
Turks have been genociding Armenians and
it comes out in his writings uh Matthew
Adessa and he literally talks about tens
of thousands of Christians being
slaughtered, thousands of churches being
torched and desecrated. Okay. And then
the same Turks were also attacking. They
they at one point they essentially
conquered Jerusalem and part mo most of
the Holy Land from the Fatimanss who
were in Egypt, a Shia dynasty. And at
that point they really started you know
a new uptick in the persecution of
European pilgrims who were coming to the
Holy Land as well. Okay. And very
graphic stuff happened to them. They
would assault them, kill them, demand
more money.
I mean, some of the most evil stuff
imaginable.
>> Yeah. And the most evil one that was
well recorded and well recounted and I
believe 1064 was a large German
pilgrimage that went and um they
slaughtered everyone and they took this
described as a very beautiful nun and
gang raped her until she died. And the
chronicler says and who was really based
on an eyewitness says and these
shameless men did this to all the
pilgrims. So all of that coalesed, the
violence happening to the eastern
christendom, the violence happening to
western Christians in the holy land,
pilgrims, um coalesed with the emperor,
the eastern Roman emperor begging for
help from the west. And then Pope Orin
in 1095, that's when he preached the
first crusade and everything I just
said, all that graphic stuff, he
mentioned as well. Okay. Um so that's
really what started it, but that's not
how it's presented now. it's presented
now as I told you five centuries of
peaceful coexistence right between
Muslims and Christians until these evil
imperial papal you know Catholic power
play decided to go and just kill Muslims
for the heck of it u because they're
just colonialists and they just want to
take their land and has nothing to do
with helping fellow Christians or trying
to help the you know to save the holy
supplr the the church that was built on
the resurrection site which was also
being attacked and was destroyed
in the year 10 uh in the year uh uh I
believe 1009 by the fatimid khalif
hakimah who raised it to the ground and
that actually called a sort of
prototypical crusade that was one of the
first or earliest callings where a pope
wanted a crusade but it didn't manifest
but then it finally did in 1095 so I'll
leave it there for now see if you have
any questions
>> yeah no I mean you touched on uh several
important point uh important points
there I think you know first of All
right, like four out of the five
original apostolic seas were conquered
by the Muslims within a couple hundred
years of the you know the rise of
Muhammad and of Islam. I mean it it
really is we consider Christryendom now
like Europe, right? But I mean like you
mentioned I mean this is Turkey is where
you know that's Asia Minor. I mean
that's where Paul preached most of his
missionary journeys was through Turkey.
So I mean this is the the cradle really
of Christian uh you know the Christian
religion and civilization. And so when
we discuss and look at the history of
Islam and Christianity I mean that you
know you want to talk about a statement
that's just totally detached from
reality. I mean it could not be further
from the truth 500 years of peace. I
mean it just utterly detached from
reality you know and so uh yeah I think
uh I would like to go back to tours
right and uh just how deep the you know
um uh caliphate had pushed into France I
mean tours is just you know like a
couple hour drive to Paris I mean they
are they were almost in the heart of
Europe I mean it really can't uh the
gravity of the situation really can't be
underscored here so yeah if you could
just uh you know Yeah. Yeah. So,
basically, as I mentioned, in 7-Eleven,
the Muslims, you know, uh, entered Spain
and conquered it. Uh, and again, very
and and it's, you know, it's worth
actually spending a little time about
Spain because another one of those great
myths that people like to say is that
somehow the Muslims, they didn't even
really conquer Spain. They just entered
it and the people were tired of the
Visig Gothic nobles and it sort of
collapsed right away and there was very
little bloodshed. And that's sort of how
it's presented and implied. But if you
look at the sources as I did and I think
in Sword and Scitar I believe chapter uh
three I spent a lot of time talking
about the early invasion and it was
exactly that. It was an invasion with a
lot of again the usual horrific
massacres. One instance that comes to
mind is you know they had all these
Christians were holed up in the church
because they wouldn't resist. They
didn't want to convert to Islam and the
Muslims uh torched it and burned them
alive. Okay. So yeah there definitely
was resistance to Islam even back then
in the 8th century when it first
entered. But of course they continued um
northward and and across the Pin
Mountains. I don't know if I pronounced
that right, but um and uh entered into
France. And again, if you look at the
sources, what they were just completely
raiding and devastating and enslaving uh
Christians
um because there was always a premium
for white flesh, white slaves. So that
was another uh incentive for them. And
they went there and again according to
the sources I have it in the book but
something like uh I believe the the the
the chief the Muslim captain I think his
name is Abd Rahman had something like
60,000 fighters um and they were going
they they were especially interested in
sacking churches and plundering them
because churches of course had a lot of
golden vessels and precious reh precious
items there. So, they were on their way
uh to the I think um the church of uh of
Martin of St. Tor I'm messing it up.
It's been so long since I've looked at
it. But anyway, that's that was one of
their goals. And then the Franks under
Charles Martell, Charles the Hammer, he
rallied a much smaller army. I think it
was maybe 25,000.
And um you know anyway you can look at
the story or the battle but they met and
they fought and uh it was pretty
horrific and a lot of carnage and it was
one of the earliest written about
sources in the Latin text that gives a
lot of like decent detail compared to
the earlier battles and uh of course it
was very important because had it not
been for that um the Muslims here's
again what they don't tell you. So on
the one hand they try to present if you
look and I quote I quote all these
academics and encyclopedias saying that
the battle of tours was just a raid a
large raid the Muslim just wanted to
come and raid and go back okay which
yeah of course that's the that's always
the initial interest you're raiding
that's the immediate impulse you're
going to get something out of it um but
that's what every jihad was it starts
off as a raid but when they conquer then
it becomes consolidated and part of the
um okay so I don't know why they're
saying that but there's even evidence
that when you look in the Islamic
sources which I quote that this was sort
of a pinser movement because this
happened right at the same time or
around the same time that Constantinople
was being bombarded and attacked in the
east by the caliphate by the Umayats. Um
so there was this idea that uh they
wanted to sort of you know but come in
through the east through Europe and the
west through France and kind of meet in
the middle and that's the end of Europe.
Now Europe has been conquered. Uh so it
it definitely was a raid for plunder as
all jihad raids are, but the long
picture was to conquer and bring it in
under the orbit or bring it into the um
that's pretty clear, especially if you
look at the Islamic sources, which is
why Edward Gibbon famously said
something about how had Charles Martell
not been successful at at at the battle
of Tours, you know, the Quran would be
preached in Oxford. Now he's writing in
uh you know, the 19th century. And his
point is of course that when he says
that he means that uh London would be um
Islamic but of course the Quran is now
being preached and taught in Oxde right
the UK but not by force or conquest by
essentially capitulation that's a whole
other story. Uh so yeah that's just
that's the importance of the battle of
tours and that's why it's one of my in
sword and I have eight battles and it's
the third one that I talk about as
highly decisive for that very reason.
Yeah, absolutely. You know, and um what
was one of the other points you touched
on earlier as well, right, is that you
know, when ISIS represents their
theology, it is I mean, it is the
historic and accurate representation of
Islam, right? I mean, we can look at and
I know people love to quote the earlier
sections of the Quran, right, where
Muhammad talks, you know, very glowingly
about the Torah and the Gospel and
Christians, right? That, you know,
they're all people of the book. Well, I
mean you look at the life of Muhammad,
he was saying this at a point where his
people were not yet in power. And so
later on in the Quran once uh you know
Muhammad comes to power, right? And he
is the dominant authority. You know all
this uh this people of the book stuff
goes out the window and as you mentioned
right everyone is given three options.
You either convert to Islam, you submit
and pay you know your ja uh as adei a
special tax right that unbelievers would
have to pay or you die. Those are the
three options.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. The it's a lot of
people don't want to admit it because
it, you know, the the implications are
so troubling, but yeah, the the Islam
espoused and promoted by ISIS is
definitely historic Islam, right? Um
what they do, okay, whether the horrific
stuff they do and burn people alive and
decapitate them and even crucify them,
that's what the caliphates did. That's
what the Sultanates did. And the that
they were the representatives of Islam.
These were the high authorities and they
had a whole cadre of and shakes and
mufties uh validating the savagery that
they engaged in mass slavery destroying
churches and other religious temples.
That is the history of Islam and like I
said it comes out very clearly uh when
you look at the the long history there's
it's just unwavering. It happened
everywhere. Okay. Even in Russia which
when you hear of the Tatar yokek which
is a Mongolian the golden horde as it's
called well they were Muslims and once
they became once those t that group of
tatars or Mongols became Muslim
immediately the same sort of you know
religious hostility that dynamic becomes
evident against the Russians. Okay so
the same things that we're talking
about. So wherever that is Islam it is
unwavering. And the point of course
about Muhammad, yeah, that's this is how
Muslims themselves have articulated and
understood the great contradictions in
their in their holy book, the Quran,
because yes, the Quran, if you want to
find peaceful, tolerant verses, they're
there and you want to find the very
violent ones, they're there, too. So,
Muslims immediately were like, well, so
what are we going to do? Which do we
follow? And this is where the um the
doctrine of al-Ness, which means the
abregated and the abregator, came up.
And in a nutshell, it's basically uh you
know whatever revelations verses
Muhammad proclaimed or they came to him
as it's understood uh the later
supersede the former or abrogate them.
Okay. So as it happens all the early
peaceful verses came to him earlier in
his career when he was in Mecca and he
was completely outnumbered and he was
not a fighter and he was not a warrior
or warlord and if anything he was the
one who was being harassed and possibly
even persecuted as they say Muslims okay
and um so that's where you get you know
you have your religion I have mine let's
live in peace then he goes to Medina and
becomes essentially a warlord starts you
know waging uh caravan raids and
terrorist attacks essentially as he
calls them one by one and and he becomes
stronger and stronger and more people
rally to him and then he starts getting
the violent verses right and these are
known as the Medina verses the later
verses and those are the ones like Quran
9:29 which is says you know fight the
people of the book until they convert to
Islam or pages with willing submission
and feel themselves subdued or of course
die and also uh Quran 95 which is slave
the pagans and the idoltors wherever you
find them. Okay? But if if they become
Muslim then let them go. All right? And
these are known collectively actually in
Arabic as the sword verses and these are
much much later in his career. So they
abregate and supersede the peaceful
ones. That's how Islamic law understands
it. But there's another dimension to all
this which few people understand and
that's that yeah the entire Quran is
still applicable to Muslims based on
their circumstances. So if they find
themselves living like Muhammad when he
was in Mecca in his early career when
he's weaker and outnumbered then they
can embrace and preach those verses
about tolerance and um cooperation and
you have your religion in mind. So if
you're a Muslim living in America, you
should preach that. Okay? But once the
circumstance changes and you're in the
majority, well, now just like Muhammad
switched his tactics once he became
stronger and now you got the new
revelation from Allah, which is to go on
on the war path, then you should do
that. And there's a funny anecdote I'll
close with because I've shared it
before, but I think it's very telling.
When I worked at the Library of
Congress, I um there were a lot of
Muslims there and one of them was we
were on friendly terms, he and I, and we
would always debate religion, you know,
engage in interfaith dialogue and I
brought all this up. You know, I
mentioned this whole issue of abrogation
because he was quoting the peaceful
verses.
>> Sure.
>> And I told him, well, that's the Mechan
verses. Those are the the the you know,
they've been abregated and superseded by
the violent ones. And he would argue
back and forth. Um and then finally he
got really frustrated and he just said,
"Well, what do you want? I'm in Mecca,
right? And his point is he's living in
this is in Washington DC, the USA. So
for him that's like Muhammad in Mecca.
I'm outnumbered. I'm weak. Of course I'm
going to preach peace and tolerance.
Okay. So I I found that very telling
when he was finally, you know, pushed up
against the wall that he admitted it
like that.
>> Yeah. No, indeed. And you know another
thing that complicates this situation
right for those who are not familiar
with Islam uh they are allowed to lie to
non-believers right it's called takia so
you know even the statements that they
make cannot be taken at face value you
know it is uh when we talk about really
deception right as a as a means of
warfare uh Islam and the caliphate are
expertly trained in this
>> yeah yeah tea and there's many other
doctrines of deception that I've I've
traced over the you know the last two
decades and I've written about and you
know the long and short of it is Islam
is very much um a practical religion in
that
whatever is convenient for the Muslim
especially visav the infidel because the
infidel is by is by default the enemy so
anything that can help the Muslim um
even though it's it's normally a sin
let's say like lying is you know not
obviously it's not frowned up it's
frowned upon on in Islam in general, but
there are caveats and ways to get around
it, especially uh you know, so if it's
the infidel, you don't even need a
caveat. Of course, you can lie because
he's persecuting you and you're good.
You're the Muslim. He's evil by nature.
So, of course, if you want to say
anything you want, you can do it. And um
this is again in the Quran. This is what
justifies tea. There's several verses
but the main one is uh 3:28 which uh you
know in the context of telling Muslims
you cannot be friends with non-Muslims
including Jews and Christians um you
have to only you you can only have
enmity and hatred for them which is
Quran 64 says that um it says
it says unless you do it by way of
precaution that's English translation
one of them of the word ta um which
means fear okay so if you if you are
friends and allies with them, Jews and
Christians and non-Muslims in general be
just for the heck of it, well, you're
you're going to hell for that. But if
you're doing it because you're you're
like Muhammad and Mecca, you're weak,
okay, and you still have your true Islam
in your heart, then that's acceptable.
Okay, so that's just one verse, but
there's a lot of hadith as well. Um, but
I there's a lot of lesser known um, you
know, lesser doctrines that the people
know that I find also interesting. One
of them for example which Muslims can
use with fellow Muslims.
This is what I mean by the elasticity of
Islam is called
in Arabic. And what that means is as
long as your words are not technically a
lie but they are uh they they are
formulated the way you formulate them so
you can get out of a bind or lie then
it's okay. And so the example for for
example is let's say um someone asks me
hey can I borrow a dollar right and I
have a dollar in my pocket but I say I
don't have a penny on me okay so that's
true I don't have a penny on me okay and
so but he understands it as me saying I
don't have any money on me even though I
have a dollar in my pocket that's not a
lie okay according to a lot of Islamic
clerics and shakes okay
>> lying by omission essentially
Yeah. Yeah. Well, it's by omission, but
also by sort of a word play,
>> you know, a double entandre. What you're
doing is you're, you know, um or another
one I saw Muslims were boasting about
how like uh I don't know. It just in
other words, it allows for a lot of
lying, but you just have to be creative
about it. Okay? The words have to sort
of fit the meaning and then it's legit.
You didn't sin. Okay? But anyway, so
like I said, that's that's for Muslim on
Muslim deception. But when it comes to
the non-Muslim, remember Muhammad
himself famously said, "War is deceit."
Okay. Well, all right. And on but the
first premise is Muslims and non-Muslims
are constantly at war thanks to Islam
because it doesn't have to be waged, but
the hostility has to always be there. So
this is why caliphates when they were
powerful and they could, they would
always wage jihad against their
neighbors. uh sometime it was it was
required according to a lot of the
clerics twice a year a raid okay but if
they're weak right then you you you're
not going to do that because it's
suicidal so this is why Saudi Arabia can
be our friend and ally even though it
teaches all its Muslims what I'm talking
about uh what Islam what Saudi Arabia
and these Gulf nations teach is
basically what ISIS teaches ISIS are
called copice and and Saudis are called
Wahhabis but move beyond that uh they're
the same exact thing which are their
literalists. They're hanbalists. They
follow the hanbali school of law which
is very very literal and um
fundamentalist. So uh how do they Saudi
Arabia get get past all this? Well they
know they're weak right now. They're
dependent on the west etc. So they're
not going to call for a fullout jihad
but and so that too is dissembling. In
fact, I once translated the uh after one
of the many famous Saudi and and US sort
of meetings and they danced together
waving swords and imply that they're
great friends. I came across a uh on an
official Saudi website of fatwa uh which
is basically a decree reminding Muslims
that they have to hate non-Muslims even
if they live among them even if they
benefit off of them like in the west. Um
and of course they can do ta they don't
have to show the hate but in their heart
they have to hate them. Okay. So that
that's what what non-Muslims have to
contend with. There's a lot of layers uh
going on in regards to the deception.
And your average westerner is so beyond
naive they can't even begin to imagine
what's going on right underneath their
nose. But and that's one of the main
reasons we are where we are.
>> Yeah. No indeed. I think for the average
person right it's just difficult to
imagine engaging in that level of
constant deception right I mean it's
difficult and I mean like we see in you
know most Muslims in the west are pe you
know are peaceful right I mean it's
difficult for them to kind of live with
some of this cognitive dissonance as
well as you were mentioning earlier with
your acquaintance there so you know it
really is uh it is so important to
discuss these issues right again one of
the things I like to do as well is to go
to those firsthand those primary sources
right because People have a lot of
opinions on the matter, but once you
read the words of some of these
firsthand and eyewitnesses to these uh
these attacks and these monstrosities,
it is just uh it's difficult to stomach
the kind of lies that you know this uh
this PhD was spouting, right? 500 years
of peace. I mean, it is again, not to
get graphic, but the most horrific
violence perpetrated against peaceful
missionaries and Christians, constant
raids and warfare, uh you know, leading
up to 1095, right? you know, putting
aside the issue of whether you think uh
you know, the ecclesiastical authorities
uh should have that ability to call, you
know, a crusade or something of the
like, right? Even putting that aside
just from a geopolitical standpoint,
right? Like this was hundreds of years
of invasions of warfare. And, you know,
at this point, I very much see it as
self-defense. You know, I don't know
your opinion on the matter. I would
assume similarly.
>> Yeah. Um, by the way, I just realized my
microphone wasn't connected. I just
connected it right now. Uh, was I
sounding okay earlier?
>> Yeah. No, no, I sounded fine.
>> Okay. Do I sound better now? Does it
even matter?
>> Um, uh, I can't tell too much of a
difference now.
>> Okay. Okay, good. And maybe if it
requires any adjusting, you can do it on
your end. But, um, yeah. So,
self-defense, that is the whole point,
right? Um, that is most people don't
realize even the Crusades were seen as
self-defense. Okay. Um, but it doesn't
look that way if you don't know the
context and the background, which most
people don't, and all you see is large
bodies of Christians traveling from
Europe to so-called the Muslim world,
which you also don't know used to be
Christian and was conquered. Um because
one of the you know most simple tenets
of just war theory which is grounded in
Islamic I'm sorry Christian teaching
including New Testament teaching u but
of course old testament as well is that
um the liberation of formerly Christian
regions. And so like I just pointed out
all of the Islamic corp uh is is built
to top non-Muslim blood and land but
especially the North Africa Middle East
region and the holy land that was all
Christian in the 7th century Christian
ruled and Christian majority people. So
the crusaders and Europeans were aware
of that. But then in the other condition
the other main condition of just war
theory was also satisfied in that they
were attacking and killing Christians.
as I mentioned uh both Eastern
Christians and uh Western European
pilgrims who were going there. So
absolutely even the Crusades were seen
as a uh as a sort of self-defense and
fit in perfectly with just war theory.
>> Yeah. No, certainly. And um man, I think
that's probably a good uh place to segue
into, you know, the modern persecution
that's going on in many of these same
places. I know you talked about your
roots as a a Coptic Christian and some
of the persecution in Egypt, but it's
not just Egypt. I mean, all across
Africa over the last decade, uh the
attacks and violence against Christians
have been intensifying. And so, I know
you're one of the few uh the few people
out there um with a large platform
talking about this issue, sir. So, yeah,
just um why are more Christians not
talking about what's going on here?
Um it ranges from probably the
fundamental reason is Christians in the
west and people in the west in general
talk only about what the media wants
them to talk about. So whatever the
media on any given day decides this is
what we're going to talk about. Taylor
Swift said something well everyone
rallies and talks about it either from a
pro or con angle right you either are
angry about it or you're happy about it.
So a lot of it has to do with stupidity
obviously. Um, that's the number one
reason and of course the media doesn't
want to talk about this particular topic
for obvious reasons because a it makes
Muslims look bad and b it makes
Christians look like victims when we all
know Christians are the evildoers of
course thanks to Hollywood. So that's
one of the main reasons I would say
that's the fundamental reason. Um you
know I think a lesser reason is amongst
certain
um denominations in the west they look
at the Christians over there a lot of
them are Catholic and um orthodox
example and they don't count them as
real Christians okay
>> um I think this would be the case with
the so-called evangelicals
>> they that's just to then you know
they're more interested in esquetology
and you know bringing Christ for a
thousand years of reigning etc etc stuff
that no one has ever heard of
historically until about a century ago.
So to them, you know, their mindset,
their entire paradigm is very very
different.
>> Yeah. And I know esquetology is one of
the subjects uh one of the subjects
we've touched upon quite a bit here, you
know, and it really is uh one of the
things that really stood out to me when
I was, you know, researching the history
of dispensationalism is just how this
has been wielded as a really a geo
geopolitical tool. And uh you know you
talk about just
>> I mean Jesus says in John 15 right that
we will know who is a true Christian by
how they demonstrate love for other
Christians right and I can't think of a
greater indictment against most American
churches than that they are utterly
uncaring of what's happening to our
brothers and sisters across the world.
>> Yeah. And isn't it funny? These are this
these same Christians in America, for
example, are the first ones who will
condemn the crusaders
for not being true Christians. When
those guys, the crusaders sold
everything, you know, lost so much when
they left Europe, a lot of them, you
have to remember, were rich nobles and
they donated, sold their properties just
so they can raise armies to go there.
And a lot of them died. Okay. So to your
you know so soft if feet you know living
in the world western Christian who you
can't differentiate from a secular
person you know they feel holier than
thou against those silly crusaders those
evil crusaders who actually died um you
know defending fellow Christians that's
that's quite the irony I think.
>> Yeah it's very easy to pide signal in
your air conditioning isn't it? Yeah.
>> And you know,
>> and and you know, going back to
prophecy, I just find it amazing that,
you know, these are the same Christians
today who claim they're biblical
Christians, and they seem to overlook
that Jesus told them nobody knows when
the second coming is. Okay, don't even
bother. Um, you know, for me, it's
anyone all, you know, this whole sort
of, you know, prophecy industry, which
I'm not too fond of. I'm something about
myself.
>> What's that?
>> I said industry is a great term.
>> Yeah. And I'm a partial predtoist, which
means I think most of the prophecies in
the Bible were fulfilled.
>> Yeah, I am as well.
>> Yeah, it's the only sensible thing. And
most church, you know, church fathers
and theologians throughout history,
that's how they saw it too because
that's the truth. But um to me, I just,
you know, whenever I find these people
who are just so caught up on prophecy
and when the second coming and etc,
etc., you know, here, let me give you
the real prophecy you need to know. And
I'm I'm going to right now I'm going to
prophesy when you and I are going to see
the second coming. It's when you die.
And that's going to happen. That I can
assure you is going to happen. It's
going to it could happen today. Could
happen decades from now depending on
your age. But once you die, that is the
uh essentual equivalent of the second
coming because now it's just you know
like a scroll turning over. You enter
into the new realm. Okay. So that's the
only thing I think people should be
cognizant of when they want to when
they're very eager to learn when the
second coming is. It's uh well when you
die and that is going to happen. So,
don't worry about, you know, trying to
piece it together and reading all these
silly books and following all these
silly so-called theologians, Christian
theologians who want you to believe this
is when the second coming is going to
happen, etc.
>> And, you know, one of the things that
people just seem to miss in all this
speculation, right, is that Jesus very
intentionally did not disclose this
information to even the apostles because
they didn't need to know. They didn't
need to be concerned about these things
because when you have that, you know,
that that final date on the calendar,
right? I mean it it does work, you know,
some complacency. I mean, we certainly
see that in the American church, right?
You know, just waiting for waiting to be
raptured so we don't have to deal with
any of these problems.
>> Well,
>> so when you talk about why Christians
don't care, here's another one that I
hear often. Um, and it's probably from
the people that you're describing when,
let's say, if I talk about the
persecution of Christians, a lot of them
will say, "Yeah, that's too bad, but
don't worry. Jesus is coming and he'll
fix it."
Okay. Well, you know, I mean, talk about
and you talk about taking the easy
route, you know, I'm not going to do
anything. I'm not gonna be
inconvenienced, even though Jesus
actually was all about telling me to do
stuff, okay? To do something for your
fellow man. Um, but now I'm just going
to sit back because Jesus will take care
of it.
>> Yeah. I think there's a parable about a
wicked servant sitting on his talents,
you know? Maybe I'm misremembering
something, though.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. No, that's Yeah.
>> Oh, yeah. Indeed. So, and uh I know you
mentioned it earlier, right? Another
important thing to remember in this
context you know so frequently the
crusades are painted in you know this
colonial or imperial imperialist uh
light but uh the vast majority of the
European nobles did not go I mean I
think only like 10% of the European
nobles went on the crusades and again
many of them were bankrupted entire
households wiped out right I mean it is
just like you saw in uh you know world
war I right you know these European
great European conflicts I mean just
entire families wiped out So it is uh
the crusaders went there at great cost,
great personal cost financially and you
know and obviously physically as well
>> and now they presented as the as usual
you know the lies are always you know
exact you know 180 degrees and now it's
presented as um they went exclusively to
make money and plunder and you know
because they were so-called second sons.
This was sort of the thesis advanced by
um Steven Runsman, crusades historian,
and everyone followed it, which is
basically all these second disinherited
sons had Noah decided to go crusading so
they can carve out their own little
kingdoms. But that's been debunked
recently by other academic crusade
historians to show you that it's the
exact opposite. It's what we just said,
which is they were actually bankrupt,
most of them, and they lost everything.
And they knew they would. And you know
one of the verses while we were talking
that they often would mention in the
context of going on a crusade is the one
that talk where Jesus talks about loving
your fellow man and loving God. So to
them loving your fellow man meant I'm
going to go and help the Christians in
the east who were being slaughtered. And
loving God meant I'm going to go and
liberate the holy land because h you
know holy land and places were important
to Christians back then. And you can't
have the holy supplr being desecrated by
Muslims and infidels and destroyed, you
know, the place where Christ was uh
buried in rose. So that's that was their
one of their expression of loving God as
well.
>> Yeah, it really is just uh it's a
travesty how these great heroes of the
faith have been painted in modern times
and how so many Christians have just,
you know, totally accepted this, right?
instead of like digging just a little
bit deeper, you know, it's like, oh,
well, I disagree with you on theology or
esquetology or, you know, siology. So,
you know, I guess you're not really a
Christian. It's just, yeah, I'll never
understand that.
>> Yeah. Today's modern Western Christians,
I call them doormat Christians. You
know, they're just uh they were they're
basically created by evil forces that
hate Christianity because the kind of
Christianity that they espouse is this
is the sort of Christianity that is very
accommodate accommodating to every kind
of evil you can imagine. It's dormat
Christianity. They think they're that,
you know, Christianity and Jesus is
preaching everything begins and ends
with me being tolerant and turning the
other cheek and never judging, etc. And
that's just not historic Christianity.
That's not even biblical Christianity
because what they're doing is they're
they're focusing on certain verses and
ignoring others. Okay? I mean, Jesus
himself engaged in violence. You know,
how's that where he made a sword of whip
and whipped people and animals and threw
tables. I mean, that's violence. So even
Jesus himself,
>> what's that?
>> So three different times.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So but to your modern day
Christian and a lot of it, you know, I
think this sort of um
non-confrontational Christianity that
permeates especially in the west, I
think a lot of it is uh on the one hand
it's promoted obviously, but on the
other hand, it's also the easy kind of
Christianity. It's uh you know, people
are making a virtue out of a vice. It's
much easier to be non-confrontational,
non-judgment, non-judgmental, and just
be a doormat than to actually stand up
and speak up and heaven forbid do
something. So, um I think a lot of it
also just has to do with innate
cowardice.
>> Yeah, I um you know, unfortunately I
have to agree with you, right? It really
is just the easy way out. You know, and
tolerance is frankly just not a
Christian virtue. You know, when we talk
about God being love, the way that we
love and the way that God loves is very
different. You know, like he establishes
in his word that the way that we love
our brothers is we show them their
errors, right? We don't just say, "Hey,
you know, you're an error. Just go do
what you want to do, right?" Like
obviously not everyone's going to
listen, but uh you at least got to say
something. Now, the idea that, you know,
just live and let live is again totally
foreign to the scriptures and obviously
historic Christianity. And a perfect
example of that, you know, which really
underscores everything we're talking
about, including, you know, self-defense
and just war is and um when you look at
Jesus, right, he performs miracles, he
heals people, he does what they want,
but then he what does he tell them? He
always tells them to repent, right? He
tells them change your evil ways, etc.
Um but then when the Roman centurion
comes to him and you know asks him to
heal his uh his servant and Jesus
complies and then well Jesus in that
instance didn't tell that guy to repent
and leave the army did he? Uh you would
think that if Jesus was against violence
and bloodshed and warfare if anyone had
to repent it's this heathen Roman
centurion who was in charge of you know
countless much bloodshed I'm sure and
everyone knew that especially in
Jerusalem. You didn't tell him that. You
didn't say, "Oh, shed your your sword
and leave the army." Uh, repent, right?
And I think there's a reason for that.
And this is in fact what a lot of the
early church fathers pointed to as
justification, implicit justification
for self-defense and just war. And John
the Baptist did the same thing when
soldiers came to him saying, you know,
what must we do to be saved? Uh, he
didn't tell them, get out of the army.
He said, be content with your wages.
Okay? So uh you know you can it's it's
all there in the New Testament
justifications for self-defense even
aggression okay and intolerance for evil
but again for your average modern day
Christian it's been weaponized the sort
of the the the turn the other cheek
aspect has been weaponized to turn them
into doormats uh you know if I hate
Christianity and I hate Christians I
would love the kind of Christianity that
exists today in the west because it's so
accommodating and it lets these
Christians think they're Christians, but
they're not. And I get away with what
I'm doing.
>> Yeah. I mean, certainly the powers that
be love a Christianity that is not a
threat to evil. So, you know, a
Christianity that just is willing to
Yeah. accommodates and tolerates it.
Absolutely. You know, so
>> now I know as we're uh you know, getting
closer to the end here, um I know uh
want to touch on your new book, The Two
Swords of Christ. So yeah, just uh share
a little bit uh of that with us if you
don't mind uh what you're going to be
diving into.
>> Sure. Well, yeah, it actually it's very
relevant to what we're discussing. Um
and uh it's basically so it's actually
part of what I consider a trilogy. So I
told you the first one is this sword and
the sword and scimitar. Then the second
one, defenders of the west, the
Christian heroes who stood against
Islam. And this book sort of does what
these two do uh in in its own way. So
sword and scimitar is just a long
history of conflict. The two swords of
Christ is and defenders of the west kind
of showcases the heroism of individuals
and that happens as well in two swords
of Christ. So what that book is about is
the two military orders the greatest
milit Christian military orders which uh
are the templars or the knights of the
temple and the knights of the hospital
the hospitalers and templars. Um, so
that's what the book is about. And the
the title, The Two Swords of Christ,
it's sort of a pun. Um, I'm referencing,
of course, the verse, I think it's in
Luke, where, you know, Jesus literally
here we here we go again with, you know,
the verses that modern day Christians
just completely ignore. But he tells his
disciples to sell their garments and go
buy swords. And they say, "Lord, look,
here are two." And he says, "That's
enough." So you know to so today what
does that mean to your average
Christian? It means absolutely nothing.
They'll tell you oh this is symbolic. It
has absolutely no significance
swords.
>> Yeah. But to earlier Christians um you
know no Jesus wasn't just talking
nonsense. He was actually making a
point. So he mentioned swords because he
meant swords. And what what it meant to
them two swords are enough is that
Christians need two swords. One to fight
spiritual evil which I guess Christians
today would agree with. But and another
one to fight physical real evil, human
evil. Okay. Um in the context of
self-defense, crusader logic. So that's
those were the two swords. And if you
have that, that is enough because you're
you're now well prepared to meet both
realms, the metaphysical and the
physical. So um that's why I called it
the two swords of Christ. But it was
also interesting because the there were
really there's there were more military
orders, but the two primary ones who
were really dominant were the Templars
and the hospitalers. So in many ways
they came to represent the two swords of
Christ actually for me because they
believed they quoted that verse all the
time and others um and you know so who
they were and what the book is about is
basically uh you know long story short
they were essentially but both of them
were monks you know monk groups
the hospitals are even older so they it
was a it was a mon it was a the hospital
was the origins of the hospital which
was again in Jerusalem and trying to
help pilgrims who were being attacked
and killed
Um, and they eventually found out, we
have to be militarized. We have to fight
back rather than sitting around and
waiting for Christians to get mauled,
which they would by Muslims. Okay, why
don't we actually go and defend them? So
that's what the Templars were and
they're the first military order. They
wanted to defend Christian pilgrims who
were being attacked even after Jerusalem
was secured. And the hospitalers, it was
the same thing, but they came they
became militarized later. Uh so the book
really looks at the theological
underpinnings of of militant
Christianity as expressed in these two
military orders and it also uh looks of
course at their history uh their entire
history. Basically that's what the book
of this book is actually my longest.
It's over 500 pages. I went a little
overboard with it. And um it's also the
book that is I've written a lot in my
books. You'll get a lot of snippets
about the Crusades, but this one's the
most focused on the Crusades because
that's what they were. They were they
were the basically the crack units of
the crus of the Crusades. So, you have
to talk about really the Crusades
whenever you talk about them. Um, yeah.
So, that's that's basically what the
book is about. And I think it's going to
be very shocking and disturbing
especially to to the sorts of Christians
that we've been discussing who think,
you know, they can't even they can't
even open their mouth and say anything
against evil, let alone do something
about it. Um they're going to be shocked
at what these men thought and how they
believe and how they were a lot more
pious than most modern day Christians.
There's the kick in the head, right?
That guys like that who were constantly
on their hands and knees praying uh were
also fighting and killing and they
didn't find any um any contradiction in
the twain.
>> Yeah. No, I mean it really is almost
like a Marcian, you know, Marcianite uh
kind of mentality, you know, the idea
that oh well, Jesus is loving and
peaceful and and and certainly right
like we should want and desire those
things, but we also live in an evil and
fallen world. And I mean, you know,
please Christians, crack open your Old
Testament sometime, you know, um, you
know, particularly the the Mosaic law
expressly includes the right to
self-defense.
>> And when did Jesus ever abregate that?
To go back to the idea of abrogation,
did Jesus ever say, "Oh, that part is is
gone." No.
>> Yeah. I mean, it's not loving to just
allow your family, other Christians,
right? I mean, just to be butchered and
massacred. I mean, no one would do that
for their own family. I know, right? And
so when it comes to our our brothers and
sisters, why would we why would we
accept that?
>> Well, like I told you, because it's the
easy way. It's a pretext rather than
inconveniencing yourself and having and
here's the funny thing. It's not like
the West has to do what the crusaders
did. It's not like you we need to sell
our homes and go travel on foot
thousands of miles to help. Uh it's as
simple as getting, you know, our policy
makers to uh threaten a country, a
Muslim country with sanctioning and
they'll stop it, right? It's that
simple. But it's not even worth evening.
>> What's that?
>> I mean, I said we're cutting off the
funds as well, you know? I mean, we that
as well. In other words, it's very very
simple to do, but it that's how and this
is what I mean. It's just uh there's no
interest and um you know I mean look
it's very hard to get into the mindset
of the types of Christians we're talking
about. Um but you know they're just not
Christians. That's the bottom line
because they don't follow they don't
even understand what historic
Christianity is. They follow sort of a
man-made new interpretation that just is
uh a lot of them in the and some of them
I see are so beyond bizarre, you know,
and and usually those are the kinds of
Christians who think they're the only
Christians and everyone else isn't. So,
it's really ironic.
>> Oh, yeah. I could I could tell you some
stories, some of the stuff I've seen in
my circles, but uh
>> Yeah. No, I I can imagine. I've seen it,
too.
>> Yeah. It really is just a, you know, a
hyperfixation on what's to come and
totally ignoring what's around us, you
know.
>> Um, this has been one of my constant
criticisms against dispensationalism
and, you know, this uh indeed much of
futurism, right? Not, you know,
exclusively. There are those futurists
still who who realize what's at stake
here. But ultimately, you know, this
theology is one that just breeds
complacency and fatalism and that is
just nowhere nowhere in the writings of
Jesus. So, we're to work, we are to
occupy, right? The idea that uh you
know, we're just going to sit on our
behinds and wait till we all get
raptured away is just I really can't
understand. You know, it's it's a
fantastic deception
>> to me. to me that those Christians
represent the those who you know Jesus
who will come and say, "Lord, Lord, we
did miracles in your name." And he's
going to say, "I never even knew you."
Okay. That's that's that group of
Christians in my opinion.
>> Yeah. That's some of the scariest verses
in the Bible right there.
>> Yeah. And look at what it talks about.
You know, it's it the people who are
like that are the ones who did miracles.
In other words, they were the ones who
really seemed to be as Christian as
possible. They're actually engaged in
the supernatural and yet he never knew
them. So, uh, that's why the, you know,
oftentimes I also say, you know, the
Christians who wear their Christianity
on their sleeve are also, they kind of
remind me that, too, because they're
more interested in sort of, you know,
showing you that they're Christian
rather than just being a Christian.
Remember the verse about uh, you know,
don't let your right hand and left hand
know what they're doing.
>> Indeed. Yeah. It's very performative,
right? And it's like, if you're a
Christian, you shouldn't have to tell
anyone. People will know. People will
see something different,
>> right?
Yeah. No, man. We've uh touched on so
many uh great topics today. I don't know
if there's anything else uh you wanted
to cover or discuss. So,
>> no, I think this was pretty good. Pretty
comprehensive.
>> Yeah. Yes, sir. Absolutely. So, would
definitely love to have you back once
the book comes out. We can uh touch on
that and go a little bit more in depth.
You know, I love theology and uh
certainly uh certainly always excited to
talk about that.
>> Yeah, sure. Happy to.
>> Sounds good. Well, uh, just, uh, let
folks know where they can find your
work. Um, and your book, The Two Swords
of Christ, coming out November 25th. You
can get at all major retailers.
>> Yeah. Um, you know, the one-stop place
for me is my website, raymondraham.com.
R A Y M O N D I B R Ahim M.com.
and it's kind of under construction. So,
there's a little a few, you know, quirks
not working correctly, but you can find
links to my like Twitter and um other
social media, I think. And uh you'll see
a list of all the books there, too. And
you can get them all directly from
Amazon. You can also get them from my
website, signed as well through there.
Um and the new book comes out November
25th, so next month, pretty soon. And um
yeah, that's it.
>> Yeah. Well, once again, sir, uh thank
you so much for your time. I know you're
a busy man and I really can't recommend
the books to the audience highly enough.
Uh he is one of the best historians on
this subject and I just really once
again thank you sir and um God bless.
>> Yeah, thanks Kipio. God bless.